Tacoma Washington Merry Christmas Jill
Merry Christmas days how you doing
better than I deserve what's up how can
I help sustain okay Dave I got a
question I want to see if I made a dumb
decision basically okay I purchase the
vehicle and I am I mean I'm very I'm as
may be said for Joe did you pay cash
I paid partial cash for the vehicles I
paid for it I was purchasing it
after-hours for my bank so I shouldn't
give them remainders so they did like a
one day purchase order to where I wanted
them doing anger of the cash so however
I purchased the extended warranty and
I'm trying to see if it was a I'm trying
to make you see it my I kind of spoiled
myself with this purchase but I want to
see if there was a smart idea I
purchased a BMW and I have the cash to
pay for it all good so I'm just trying
to see this if it's smart to get this
extended warranty and pay cash for the
remainder of it or should I pour go that
and I guess take the risk for the
repairs so to my understanding after
researching the repairs to be pretty
expensive even though I have cash out up
for that I don't know if that is the
smartest thing so what did you pay for
the car I paid twenty five thousand for
the car okay and what's your household
income actually six thousand gloves on
and you're single
yes I am okay good all right what's less
than half your annual income you paid
cash for it got any problem with that
and you said you had cash piled up to
cover the repairs what is the cash piled
up to cover the repairs I have about
forty thousand to cover repairs but I
don't know if there's a $5,000 car you
can buy another one if you have to I'm
more of a favor yeah I can tell I can
tell you've done a good job you've done
a good job by the car and pay cash and
have you heard me talk about extended
warranties before
I heard you talk about how you're not
really a fan of them okay do you
remember Hawai I think I think it's
because you said you won't use I guess
it'll pay for itself or something like I
can't remember where alert okay
well let's walk through it and I'll
explain it and then yeah well then you
can decide okay let's walk through it
because it's good for everybody else to
listen to that's why we do this okay
alright if you and I were to open an
extended warranty company and we wanted
to sell extended warranties on BMWs that
are twenty five thousand dollars here's
what we would do we would look at the
items that we're going to cover with the
warranty the transmission the engine the
brakes the suspension whatever it is
right and then we would do statistical
analysis to determine if we cover a
thousand cars like that what are we as a
warranty company on average going to
have to pay out on these cars that
breaks right okay so we need to know
what it's going to cost us if we're the
warranty company to provide the warranty
coverage and that's a statistical
analysis of looking at actual repair
records on actual BMWs that are twenty
five thousand dollars okay that makes it
twenty five thousand is including the
ones I know by the way okay well okay
but whatever I'm using this is an
example all right oh so if we figure out
that it costs us on average X number of
dollars per thousand of these cars we
cover then that's our cost of running
our warranty business do you understand
Apollo okay on top of that if we want to
stay open we have to be able to pay the
building rent the electricity and the
secretaries that's called overhead so we
would take what it costs us that we
would have to pay out on the warranties
if we own the company we would add
overhead to it okay we would also want
to make a profit so we would add profit
to it right and by the way in happens to
be with car extended warranties that
they very seldom are the actual car
company that's a third-party company and
so we're gonna pay the guy at BMW lot
some marketing dollars commission if he
sells our warranty for us okay all right
now if you add that commission the
profit the overhead and the actual cost
to cover the car together
you have your premium for the extended
warranty okay okay okay what's
interesting is that 12% of that per
hundred dollars $12 per hundred or 120
per thousand dollars of your warranty
actually goes to cover the cost of the
car breaking the other eighty eight
percent goes to profit overhead and
commissions so in other words if you
bought a thousand dollar extended
warranty your actual coverage
statistically is around one hundred and
twenty dollars worth of repairs on
average you could have you could have a
ten thousand dollar repair but you're
the customer they lost money on that
right so point is that you don't have to
by the time you do all the repairs
yourself you will come out around eight
times better off on average if you have
an average number of repairs like the
average per thousand cars right if
you'll come out about eight times better
off having self insured through the
repairs meaning don't buy the extended
warranty because twelve percent is
one-eighth of a hundred okay so eight
times more money you're paying eight
times too much to fix your car when you
buy an extended warranty on average and
if that's not true the extend warranty
company goes out of business
because they can't pay their secretaries
they don't have any profit and they
can't pay their Commission's that make
sense so cancel the extended warranty
part of the transaction save that money
and buy this car and enjoy this car
which Beamer is it
three series 328i and I've been favored
for it what year is it music 2014 that
is a great car thank you sir
there's a fabulous it's a fabulous
vehicle it's got a lot of spunk it's got
a great Drive Rachel and Winston just
bought one and it's a it's a great car
and that little 3-series has always been
a good car this this latest version of
it is one of the best cars BMWs ever
built as far as I'm concerned they build
a good car but I'm a car guy I don't
have one right now a Beemer but that
particular vehicle is a great car you
might you bought a good car it is going
to be cause more costly to repair than a
Ford or a Chevy because it's a Beemer
just count on that this part of the
pleasure of owning of the more expensive
vehicle you can afford it you cover your
own repairs really good question thanks
for joining us and merry Christmas to
you